so I just heard that in the LinkedIn
post it was saying that I was talking
about casual models and that sells the
causal models so for those that want the
casual model I don't have those but I
hope the talk will be casual enough to
uh to follow for you
okay
um yeah so as I said I hope to inspire
you a little bit in your own project to
think about the causal and the
predictive components of the problem
that you're facing and I'll do so by
using an example of irrigation in a
greenhouse and how we apply this at
source
so this is the outline I would like to
start with a short scenario to get you
into the causal thinking mood then I'll
tell you about the problem we're
applying this to Irrigation in
greenhouses
then I'll go a little bit more to that
in how we approach this and then I hope
to give you some general advice on how
you can apply this in your own projects
so first the short story this is a
scenario and I think I can be honest
with you I'm a little bit cheaper I it
was exactly the same story that I used
last year during the padeta conference
but I just really felt it helps you to
get into the mindset of thinking about
causality
so
bear with me here comes the story so
there's a freshly Harrier data scientist
and a manager and the data science is
fresh on the job asking okay what shall
I start doing and a manager is saying
what about making a model for
predictions
for sales
I'm sure that will be something super
useful and today it's hard to ask okay
but how is it exactly going to generate
business value at which the manager
replies well we can think about it later
let's not worry I'm sure it will be
super valuable so the data scientist
goes to work
and two months later she has this
amazing model with a super small
prediction error
and at that point the manager says this
is awesome now let's predict what
happens when we change the price to
decide whether we give a discount or not
and if you ever feel you're in such a
scenario you should raise your red flag
because What's Happening Here you start
off with the purely predictive problem
and then it turns out it wasn't such a
purely predictive problem to start with
actually it's more of a causal problem
that you're looking into
so and why is it the case there's the
formula of what means it uh what does it
mean when you have a causal problem
it's when the probability of outcome y
given observed X is actually something
different than the outcome of y when you
start influencing X so these features
and this is this is something different
and this is really at the core why you
might have a problem if you start by the
predictive model and you end up
answering goals or questions in the end
I hope you're all in the causality
mindset now let's go to our topic
Irrigation in greenhouses but first why
do we have greenhouses in the first
place
nowadays still 2 billion people around
the globe suffer from malnutrition and
we have a growing population so with the
limited space we have on our planet the
only way how we can feed the world with
a healthy diet is in some sort of
controlled environment agriculture of
which greenhouses is is one option
so why does this work well it's climate
resilient it allows for local production
but moreover it gets up to 50 times as
much yield per square meter
moreover so we'll be talking a little
bit more about this topic is the water
can be recycled inside the greenhouse
which makes it much less water that you
need to use also the fertilizers can
also be recycled which is a very good
thing because you prevent any pollution
by runoff into the environment of these
fertilizers
so why don't we see much more
greenhouses around the globe
it's because there's a complication it's
if you have such a highly Advanced
Greenhouse you actually still need
Growers that can successfully operate
these greenhouses and they need to have
a lot of experience think about at least
10 years before you can do this moreover
even with an experienced grower it might
take several years because before before
you can make a new Greenhouse profitable
so what happens especially abroad where
they do not have such expert growth as
in the Netherlands they invest a lot of
money to make a sustainable greenhouse
and they go bankrupt within a year
because they do not have the expert
Growers to make it profitable
and that's where we with Source come
into play so we help Growers to solve
these challenges using machine learning
products so sources found it two years
ago and we're currently with 60 people
dedicated to helping Growers to make it
much more easy to scale Greenhouse
growing across the globe
so on to the topic of irrigation
unfortunately I can't explain all the
things that we help Growers with but
irrigation is the topic for today's talk
so how does irrigation work in
greenhouses
in these high-tech Greenhouse is
typically the plants are not inside the
normal cell but they are grown in these
kind of slabs and these slabs actually
make it possible to capture any water
that comes out of it and do this
recycling of the water and the nutrients
so that's why they're in slabs
so how does irrigation work you see
these small white tubes and black beans
and those are used by computer driven
Precision Irrigation inside these slabs
the slabs gets wet and starts filling up
with water which is called saturation
and when it's fully saturated the water
comes out in the bucket you see below in
rain and the water can be recycled and
then the middle you also see a
measurement device for how much drain is
actually coming out of the slab
so what do the roots look like so here's
a picture of healthy Roots you can see
there's a lot of roots and they are
nicely White
so if you think about water inside the
slab of course when it's a lot of sun
you want to have a lot of water for the
plants to have optimal production
however you cannot have completely wet
slabs all the time because it's not
healthy for your Roots the Roots need to
have oxygen to be healthy if you just
completely have a wet slab for a couple
of days these term brownies start to rot
and your plant dies so you want to have
a lot of water during the day but then
also have a little water and oxygen
inside the roots to have healthy plants
so it's important that we measure the
amount of water that's inside the slab
so there's two sensor types that are
mainly used to do this one is using
skills mostly using Tomatoes the
tomatoes hang from a wire and then I put
the skill underneath the slabs so you
can actually measure how much water
inside the nice property of the setup is
that you know one liter in is one
kilogram on the skills so actually
there's a physical relationship that
tells us okay what is the effect of
irrigation
however if you grow other crops like
peppers they stand on top of your slab
so it doesn't work because you also get
the weight of the of the plant
in that case we use these in-slab
sensors it's pins go inside the slab and
they can measure water content
but in this instance it's not really
clear with what the effect of irrigation
is on the water percentage inside a slab
so that's why we would need to have
something causal
so a summary how does this work you have
the slabs Walter gets in during the
irrigation shots and the water gets out
in two ways either the plant takes the
water or if the slab is fully saturated
it comes out as drain
so let's look at some data on what this
looks like so you can see during the
night the slab is quite dry so we have
percentage water inside the slab is it
fully saturated or not it's quite dry
and then in the morning you start giving
several shots and you make sure that
when the sun is shining a lot then
you're at maximum saturation so there's
a lot of water for the plant so it can
grow absolutely and then at some point
that I need to stop
and this is quite hard to decide when
you exactly need to stop because you
need to make sure that you get dry
enough during the day to maintain
healthy Roots but when you need to stop
depends on how much water the plant will
be going to take and that depends on a
lot of factors so this is a very hard
thought for growth every day think about
okay when should we stop irrigating and
that's what well you want to help them
with and you can already hear that
this problem has kind of two components
one thing we need to go up with our
shots so we need to have the causal
effect of a shot
but then also we need to know when we
stop irrigating and that's much more of
a predictive task because we need to
predict how much water the plant is
going to take so it is really two
components to it one more closer and one
more predictive
so on to our approach how do we approach
this problem
let's start with a black box approach
I'm a black box I mean just take any
features that have predictive power and
throw them into the model because if you
look at this data we actually just have
a Time series oh we have time series
methods we get a bunch of data and then
we can make nice predictions how hard
can it be so what kind of features have
predicted value it's outside weather
most importantly radiation that's
outside but it's more complicated than
that because in the greenhouse there's a
lot of controls you can open the windows
you can turn on the heating you have
screens so there's a lot of things that
influence the actual climate inside the
greenhouse
then there's lags I'll come back to lag
Sox can be very powerful for protection
but quite dangerous if you want to do
causal effect estimation and then last
but not least we have irrigation and
drain
the intervention the treatment that
we're interested in so let's just throw
all of them in to our model
so which modeling method do we like to
use I'm going to show results for
gradient boosting live GBM and a linear
regression and I would like you to
choose either of those which one do you
think is better at estimating a cause of
effect
so if you can put your hands anyone like
GBM
anyone yeah a couple couple
so linear regression you have to choose
so that's everyone else
okay this one's more
okay so first explain the graph so on
the x-axis we have the irrigation in
liters on the y-axis we have the change
in saturation inside your slab and
percentages
so and for this example I want to show
you a ground through so we actually take
the skills here and there we know one
liter in is one kilogram on the scale so
we can actually calculate what's the
ground truth here that's the blue line
and this is what we're going to use to
show you how these uh modeling methods
work
so this is the live GBM and actually I
was really surprised because this
doesn't look that bad so we kind of got
lucky even in the beginning it seems
quite near to the ground truth and then
a little bit less so yeah we got lucky
here just throwing some features and
this quite well surprisingly if we take
the linear regression it's first so
that's really giving you an idea like
okay maybe it's not really about the
specific modeling method that you use
but maybe it's all about the features
that you select
so a little bit of a side step here I
want to go into double machine learning
another method that's specifically
focused on using machine learning to
estimate goals or effects so we do the
same thing we throw the features in but
I'll take a side step and explain a
little bit about how it works
so I used to Ecom ml package I encourage
you to try it
and I'll use these formulas to explain
what it does so here again we have the
outcome Y and we have the treatment D
and what we're interested in is the
effect Theta in here which can depend on
X which are some features
if x and W and x and W together is
anything that could help you resolve
these causality problems confounding
errors it might actually be a common
cause or something that's indicating a
common cause and then the Black Box
approach we just draw anything in
so what's the id
we
actually do a regression using the
residuals of the outcome Y and the rigid
the residuals of the treatment t
and these residuals are calculated like
this so we use this formulas g x of Y
and f x of Y that we use to calculate
these residuals and the beauty of it we
can pick any machine learning model to
fit G and F and we can still get results
good causal estimations so there's a bit
of code how does it work you can use the
equal email package in this case we just
take a linear model for Theta for the
effect and then from so I could learn
you can take random Force for gas or
whatever you want to fit it you get your
point estimates and you can get
confidence interval so
please try it home for now we do exactly
the same Black Box approach select all
the features just throw it in
and as you can already expect well
purple line here well it looks better
than linear regression but it really
doesn't look that much better than just
throwing it into a live GPM model
so you don't know maybe it's not that
much about the method it's all about the
features that you select for your model
so we need to be smart about it
so how do we approach this we have this
line and if you look at it you see when
the line goes up we have irrigation and
Ray but a lot of data points inside this
graph
there's no irrigation and drain so we
know we only have the water uptake and
this is an opportunity so what is our
approach
we first train a predictive model of the
water uptake with any data point that
doesn't have irrigation and drain inside
then we use those predictions to
subtract the predicted water update from
those other data points and then we can
estimate our causal effect of irrigation
using a simple model and if needed you
can iterate a little bit between fitting
these models
and this is the result orange line as
you can see maybe not exactly ground
food but clearly much closer so it
really helps to think about what
features do you select and do you have
opportunities to fit this model in a way
where you have a predictive component
and a causal component
so going back to the viewmark before
with the live GBM we got got lucky but
we don't really want to be lucky right
we don't want to do something wrapped
maybe we get a close effect maybe not so
why does this happen in the first place
as I said legs are quite dangerous
for prediction they are quite powerful
and why is that if you look at what
happened yesterday in your saturation
and wealth of water uptake of the plant
was yesterday it's as the opportunity of
capturing a lot of things that you
cannot really measure in a greenhouse
it's just like the whole system behaves
a little bit like yesterday so that's
good
however for causal inference is
dangerous especially if we start
automatically retraining these models so
imagine if a grower changes the climate
computer so how this exactly works so
okay now I do a specific moment in time
to do this irrigation shots if that
happens instead of the model will see
that in the right exactly inside the leg
of yesterday the situation goes up and
model cannot distinguish anymore is this
because of what happened yesterday or is
this because we irrigate now so this is
a risk if you use less especially it
might look good when you start with an
urethra your model and certainly your
cause effect it just goes to [ __ ]
there's another one that's very
important is be careful with features
that might be caused by the treatment
so let's say you do some random feature
engineering and you say okay at each
shot the start time if it showed I make
a feature because maybe it's something I
need to control for my model and you put
it to the model you go wrong because the
model again can distinguish between is
the irrigation or is the start time
that's causing this and if you think
about if you're generate idlet actually
it's a cause of the three millions
rather than something that you would be
a common cause of treatment and outcome
and another example of course drain that
happens because we irrigate so be
careful with selecting it into your
model
so
that was our application and now I hope
to share a little bit some advice and
thoughts on how you can maybe think
about these goals and predictive
components in your own project
so let's say we have the scenario we
start off with a prediction problem how
can you identify that it might be that
you have some causal components to your
problem
so one of it is good to think about this
so the predicted outcome of why is it
actually something we try to influence
by changing something in the features if
so what are those features because you
need to have a causal approach for them
then generally just look through the
features and this is stuff that's
influenced by humans then probably you
should think about is the causal
component
also if you're doing scenario comparison
it could also be an indicator that you
need to have a closer approach and that
doesn't even have to be exactly that a
human is influencing but for example if
you say outside weather radiation it's
not something that we change but if for
some reason we really want to know the
effect of radiation what we do then you
have a similar problem that I've
described before the lags so remember
you have radiation but inside the legs
that we use in a model it's also kind of
the effect that the weather might be
similar to what it was yesterday so if
you throw it in the model like that you
don't really get a cause of effect per
se
so not only for things that humans can
control
and then lastly sensitivity analysis if
you find either during development or
monitoring that you're doing some kind
of sensitivity in LS says please check
that whatever you're checking in your
features you're checking your
sensitivity analysis whether it's
actually something that needs a causal
approach
in general sensitivity analysis
besides model monitoring on like
prediction performance it's a really
good idea to monitor your sensitivity
for any goals or components inside your
model because that's just what you need
to check when you retrain think about
the example where the change in the
climate computer were made I mean that's
what you want to capture if you retrain
your model
then the other way around when can we
use these predictive components it's if
we just want to do a prediction without
directly influencing the outcome then we
get more free okay don't worry too much
we can make a protective model an
example will be the water uptake we just
need a prediction for the water uptake
to define the stopping time it's not
something that we're going to actively
influence so where you can use
predictive components however also here
don't go blightly selecting features
because if you if this predictive
component you need to be careful from
all the leakage and what this means if
you need to
stop irrigating and we need to do a
prediction for during the night then
there's a lot of features inside the
data that actually isn't available at
the moment of prediction so you also
need to be careful with these components
that you actually do not create leaky
models
so how can we estimate this model first
Jack is maybe we do not need to fit a
model at all it was the example of one
liter in is one kilogram on the scales
I mean just use that right or maybe look
into the literature and maybe it's even
better to get something from literature
and use that instead of fitting your
model
then the example I gave is there might
be an opportunity to do this multi-stage
approach so in our sense first estimate
a predictive model for whatever update
and second step estimate the causal
model however it might be hard to do and
then you might want to consider doing
estimation of all these components
together and then you would have to make
a custom model in tensorflow BIO torch
or one of my favorites biome C3 if you
want to have a Bayesian approach
so there's also an option
so in my example I could show you how
well we did because I actually knew the
ground truth but in many cases you do
not know the ground too that means it's
the whole point where you're looking
into modeling this stuff right so for
testing one of the methods that you can
try if you want to test your method is
get the effect out
then put an effect in with a specific
size
and then you can touch your method and
see where they actually can retrieve the
correct effect I mean it's not 100
foolproof but it does give a way to give
you some handles on okay is my method
actually working the way I get the goals
are affected actually put inside of my
data
so
those are five to one through pink I
hope this is the takeaway just never
blindly select features for your model
really spend time thinking about them
okay what do they mean which one should
take you they're not
and then second worry about the modeling
framework
so that's it any questions
[Music]
[Applause]
you managed well within the time yeah
so does anyone have any questions for
breathen
because then we're gonna throw the
microphone
at you
oh it nice
I have a question that's actually
released the last slide that she just
showed where you explain different
methods that you can use to deal with
causality in general and what about just
a control group
yeah so okay so that's I decided not to
put it in but if you can I beat this
please A B test but in many case you
can't beat that yeah exactly because for
example we can't really do that so then
it's like yeah so then you but it's
always good to think about okay what
would an ibiz look like with us it would
be like having a lot of greenhouses and
just yeah like every random simple right
but I mean that's just too costly
because exactly yeah you just probably
are going to lose a lot of crops so
that's uh yeah
yeah so that's what if you can be the
test you should do it but keep in mind
the cost so if we give a bit more
background we do have research in this
area right so it's just going from
Wagner University so you do have this
controlled experiments where they do
this but then
um often you can't really get to this
level of detail as we do here right it
might be okay if you do not give any
water or substantially less water do we
see in our test any effect on the plants
but that's I mean good for research but
it doesn't really help but solving these
practical problems because you need to
much more precise on how you should
steer it and then it's just too costly
to do an experiment for everything
good question yeah anywhere there in the
middle
yeah get ready to catch
oh this is going so smooth hi uh
um if we keep the thing like you have to
talk into the uh star thingy you don't
have to keep it that close but oh then
we can hear you I hear my voice
and
wooden
app
be also this problem the domain of
Kalman filters
sorry like to to optimally control
basically irrigation where we have the
dynamic system the switches between what
should be during the day and what well
optimally should be during the night
like from a mechanical engineering
um
point of view usually like people
approach this also as with Kalman
filters is it something that we could
also Implement here
um with Goldman filters yeah yeah yeah
yeah so common filters goes in any
category of like uh time series like you
could do lstm like like whatever right
um You can do that for the predictive
bars but we really go over with causal
part because the exactly example of a
lack of 24 hours I mean that's just like
super many more legs inside your model
if you start using these kind of models
so it goes really hard to kind of
disentangle what's the what's the cause
of effect
um so that's one and the other one is
you if you need to predict a long time
ahead you need to think about error
propagation inside such models uh yeah
but but sure for the predictive
component I mean pick anything that that
works but for the causal components it
will be tricky
okay thanks
yeah I have a question about this this
prediction so the grower has in mind
what he wants to do for the future
things so what is the predictive part of
your uh of your model where do you use
this for
uh to decide the stopping time so it's
like the target is okay we need to reach
this dry down right but then the
question is when do you stop so we used
to predict the model to predict the
world's uptake and then you calculate
back and then you know when to stop
so that's
simple I think so the idea is that it
said also
acting as a help or replacement for an
expert that you don't necessarily need
an expert grower to tell you you have to
stop now you can use the model yeah so
that's the really hard part you really
need to imagine that you could go over
every day is to check oh how's the
weather and what we will do and should I
start earlier later and that's uh yeah I
mean that's just hard you need a lot of
experience and it just takes a lot of
work so that's where we're trying to
help them with
yeah
over there
I have an easy throw and then you miss
thanks uh thanks for the talk that's
very interesting I was wondering in uh
do you model per per plant or per plant
type and how much variability is there
like do you need to keep learning or do
you learn a model once and yeah okay
that's a very good question for the
other modeling we do it it's like how
their plan develops the type of plants
really makes a lot of difference even
between species so that's like a large
part of the job for these models they
train quite fast because we get quite a
lot of data so it's like really good and
then okay just look at the plant
Behavior now and then it's a little bit
less depending on uh on what plane you
have because I mean I mean how to play
behaves is of course depending on a lot
more things than the species of the
plants but in any case I mean we just
have the opportunity that we can learn
this pretty fast uh
so that includes like the specific
species of plants
thank you
do we have any more takers for the cube
all the way in the back you think what
the first yeah
thank you very interesting presentation
and I don't want to reiterate the first
question too much but Azure cultural
inference is notoriously difficult in
some domains right like like marketing
even if you can successfully a B test
was your marketing campaign so
successful or did the opponent's Market
campaigns suck right you don't know but
this strikes me as a domain where you
have full control over the feature space
right so you briefly mentioned you could
actually create a physical copy of the
greenhouse and just essentially a B test
away right and you could actually create
a mini version of that so I don't see
why it would be that costly okay okay so
that's going back to my previous
question right
I mean is that costly because green
arrows are expensive and you will lose
on your uh on your Harvest Right I mean
so that's the costly power to it and
especially I mean setting up a one-off
experiment is not that bad but it's like
continuously knowing okay where should
we exactly put this I mean that's really
hard so to be honest it's not even that
much of a question for us like prove
exactly how much better you did I mean
that's not worth talking about the
garage notice is super hard and we just
help them with it and if it helps them
to become successful we don't even claim
to the like with the market campaign and
say okay this is exactly the uplift we
don't even do this it's just like we
helped you achieve this also maybe give
a little back background of the plants
it's like stability for the plants is
really important because the roots
develop where the water goes and this is
really where there's also a lot of
impact it's like okay for the growth
it's really hard to get the right um
stable because of better conditions
because of everything and that's what we
help them with and that's what's really
beneficial for Our Roots
thanks
another question I think it was all the
way there in the back
yes okay
are you gonna try
no
I don't want to injure anyone so
I'm just
hey thanks for the talk
um very big respect to anyone who does
causal inference in practice
a question for you since your problem is
so practical and I imagine costly I just
wonder have you seen did you have enough
observations of the causal variable
along the specter
like the question is motivated with the
previous experience of mine that is like
sometimes it's very hard because some
things don't happen in reality right
with some combinational features yeah so
we were lucky because especially the
skills is pretty simple right you put
water in and then the weight goes up uh
if you within slaps it's a little a
little bit more complicated than that
than these but still
um the fact that it's across one feature
uh helps so you can kind of check it's
if it's inside this range so there's not
I okay you cannot model without making
assumptions right and here we make some
assumptions that
um I mean it's not like super many
interactions effects of everything you
could lose use the double machine
learning method to have even on
parametric you could do that cause of
forest but to be honest I mean the more
you allow for these kind of things the
harder and it gets like okay yeah but
what does this actually say and if you
start making predictions do we in this
High dimensionalities move somewhere out
of the area that we ever have seen Data
before so in that sense I mean it really
helps today to make assumptions but if
you can make those assumptions then
I mean then you have an interesting
challenge I suppose
that's what what's making the work fun
I mean it'll just be boring if it's just
like take your features fit your model
and that's that's it right
we have time for yeah we have a couple
minutes there yeah
hi uh thank you for the talk I was just
wondering if the physics failed in with
respect to causal inference or was there
any comparison made between physics and
causal inference uh yeah so the ground
truth here was like the physical
equation
um
yeah okay so
I think we're just saying that physics
might also not be perfect right to some
extent that's true because I mean
sensors I mean no sensors are perfect uh
so it in reality might deviate a little
bit from the ground food that I put here
but yeah still with these skills it's I
mean it's quite close right one liter in
is one kilogram so we can pretty well
calculate what what is happening with
the sensors if you ever gave
so it is possible to do like a
predictive model plus physics-based
model yeah so that's yeah exactly so uh
if you would have the skills then we
could use the physics model to do the
irrigation and then that could be the
first step and then we take the
irrigation out the effect of the
irrigation and then we can train our
predictive autopsic model so that's yeah
that would be a perfect strategy yes
okay yeah thank you
I think uh that's it for time or do you
want to do one more
we can have one more question we can do
one more question yeah yeah the
questions are amazing so please another
one
oh perfect wow no practice yes or no
so do you hear me okay uh I mean uh from
a person coming from systems and control
background I very much enjoyed the
solution because in that Community they
basically try to use dynamical models
like based on physics differential
equation and also uh Kalman filter is
also based on that and one of the
drawbacks there is that because
basically they can't always find
differential equation for models and
that's where they would use uh
data-driven methods like machine
learning and and these methods so I was
wondering if you were also able to
compare the solution that you had with
any sort of solution coming from more
like systems and control perspective
um was this let's say problem also
already addressed by a different
solution I mean causal inference because
you're you have this control signal very
much makes sense from data perspective
but I was wondering if you had other
benchmarks from different communities to
compare Your solution
uh
for exactly solving a problem like this
I don't really know about it
but I mean several other related tasks
they use indeed more control engineering
approach also we we didn't really start
off solving this problem like okay we
have to use machine learning right we
kind of looked at okay what has been
solved already and then uh yeah it came
to this approach but I mean if there's
another problem if we can help a grower
with for which we do not need to use
machine learning as I put like there's a
recommendation uh yeah then then we for
sure do that also in the other models
that we make there's quite some
components that
I mean we do not do model training to
create I mean we might think a lot about
the model always being a machine
learning world all right but I mean
that's not it doesn't have to be the
case it can be just a theoretical model
uh based on physics that you do not do
training for and it can actually work
very well so uh yeah we have some
components inside the company and yeah
there's I think a lot of applications I
think for us it's really good too also
we've had
um yeah I've had some conversations with
companies that have more this kind of
approach
system engineering
thank you very much yeah and that also
ends our time